i've asked many friends i got roger
stone coming on you wouldn't believe the
wildly different opinions i have i wrote
some of them down some of them said he's
a national treasure and he's a american
hero
some says that guy's not in jail
some says that guy is a treasonist and
he should be locked up
why are you such a polarizing figure uh
because i tell you what i really think
uh because i've beaten a lot of
democrats in elections
because i believe in loyalty look i i
was charged for one reason to pressure
me to testify falsely against trump i
refused to do that
that that aggravated a lot of people and
i was marked for destruction uh it is
only through an act of mercy and justice
that the president pardoned my uh pardon
me in my conviction but
two years after i was convicted by court
order
uh robert mueller and the doj are forced
to release the redacted section of the
report in which they admit they never
had any evidence against me a russian
collusion or wikileaks collaboration uh
or any other uh criminal act so uh no i
think good to half the people i'm a hero
to the atheist people it's a villain
i've at least made my mark it's better
than being no one yeah the uh so you're
comfortable being the villain to half of
america i don't i don't have any choice
it's not a question whether i'm
comfortable with it or not i do i do
find it odd
uh that violence has become uh you know
is become acceptable when i was if i
went to a restaurant and i saw someone
across the room that i disagreed with
politically i wouldn't start screaming
or throwing things at them or
threatening them i'd ignore them but
that that is that is not the case today
and public shaming uh and violence are
all too uh common i can't leave south
florida without a professional security
it's not violent not viable not viable
some may say that you were the the head
of the snake for the how ugly politics
is today
uh you started what they call negative
uh campaign advertising um
do you do you feel any sort of like um
i'm not gonna say remorse but like
or maybe it's pride that you were kind
of the originator of how dirty politics
is or has it always been this dirty but
you've been sort of nicknamed this dirty
trickster even though that's not the
terminology you use but they use for you
i think you once said on your tombstone
it's not going to say what you describe
yourself as the agent provocateur you're
certainly provocative
but it will likely say dirty trickster
however you don't use those words
correct so how would you explain that uh
you know abraham lincoln's opponents
handed out leaflets saying that he was a
mixed race i'm sorry i didn't i didn't
invent negative power politicians you
weren't around in the lincoln days
i was not the head of youth for lincoln
uh the point i'm making is that politics
has always been a contact sport in
america uh i didn't change that i'm not
responsible for that i have always
played the game by the rules and the
laws by which it is regulated as
politics has changed you have to change
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]